holiday season is usually a busy time
for non-profits but the pandemic forced
opportunity village to cancel
two major events this year that includes
the holiday favorite magical forest
what is moving forward though is the
santa run it will be virtual though
opportunity village is also turning now
to the cookie business look at this
the group is making thousands of frozen
cookies out of its bakery
officially launches tomorrow you can
then buy them the non-profit relies on
these types of events to fund programs
that help adults with intellectual
disabilities
the non-profit world it's a crisis for
us and and
no matter what's going on we have people
out there with need that need resources
people with disabilities they want to
have a life just like you and i
they want to be able to go to work they
want to be able to have those things and
so without
the community we're not able to make
those things happen
as they try to help our community they
are asking anyone who can make a
donation to please do so online
you can also swing by the thrift store
you can volunteer virtually
they also have some great handcrafted
gifts sold on their website too